at first glance this lake near airline
in germany looks picturesque and
peaceful but beneath the waters lurks a
menacing danger a snapping turtle
visitors to the lake say they saw the
dangerous reptile three and a half weeks
ago for some that's evidence enough it
left us on it I think there's one there
because I believe those that say they
saw the turtle sadly there are no photos
photo a snapping turtle has a powerful
bite that's how it earned the nickname
Suarez after the Uruguayan football star
but this is a more accurate image up to
a meter long and weighing 30 kilograms
favorite items on the menu for the
reclusive turtle fish amphibians and
birds nevertheless the residents in ere
long and are on the alert men's it's
virus if they bite they can actually
inflict serious wounds that require
professional medical attention even
surgery to avoid any such biting
incident residents have decided to try
and trap Suarez but the question has to
be asked who's going to strike first